[Music]
as we talk about the mechanics of these
great expeditions from the beginning of
the 20th century it's important to think
about who was doing the work and how the
information was being disseminated so in
this section I'd like to talk a little
bit about the Egyptian workmen so often
in the literature the focus because
these are Western expeditions organized
by Westerners British French German
Italian Americans the focus is on these
individuals the three or four or five
foreigners who come in and run the dig
they're the ones doing the writing
they're the ones disseminating the
publications and so there's been a focus
you might almost say an over focus on
their achievements and lost in the sauce
in a way are the achievements of the
Egyptians now they're the ones of course
doing the work and maybe many of them
are illiterate and they're not writing
up publications of the work but
nevertheless some of them reached
tremendously skilled Heights and were
integral to the success of many of these
expeditions in fact a tradition was
started by Flinders Petrie of going to a
place called cuffed and recruiting
individuals there who then became so
adept in archaeological method that they
were always the foremen the rious of the
expedition and so this tradition
expanded far beyond Petrie to the point
where everyone wants a goofty to be in
charge of the other perhaps less skilled
labor on an expedition we still do this
today so cooked is quite famous for
delivering archaeological talent native
archaeological talent so in the old days
of course there were 75 men a hundred
men a hundred and fifty men it was a lot
to organize and to keep them paid and
keep the fundraising going and in this
section I just like to highlight a few
of these images and you can see how hard
the men are working and then of course
what a family atmosphere developed along
the way this is a sort of team photo in
the 1930s and you see George Reisner
over on the right he's smiling one of
the few times he smiles in one of these
photos and standing with them is mr.
edge oh the Museum of Fine Arts director
who's actually come out to jeez
for a visit so while there might have
been 75 or 100 hundred 50 workmen the
group you see here are the core of the
expedition these are the ones handling
the accounts making the decisions
overseeing the men driving the cars
cooking the meals taking dictation and
helping typing up the manuscripts
solving problems and disputes lending
money handling funerals you name it and
in fact George Reisner came to be a sort
of father figure for these individuals
many of them started with him as boys
grew up in his presence and in fact had
families and children and the children
started to work for the expedition too
so you can imagine what a calamity it
was when he finally died in 1942 many of
these people had known no other career
no other employment and they were in
effect set adrift it's time to put names
to these faces and to give credit where
credit is due
the Egyptians came to revere Reisner and
they looked up to him as a great leader
in fact some of them even nominated him
to be the Khedive and a newspaper
article in 1914 that made it all the way
back to the Boston press that must have
it a little embarrassing for George
Reisner but all of this was based of
course at Harvard camp where the red
arrow is pointing in this aerial
photograph so this is west of the khafre
pyramid this collection of modest mud
brick buildings grew over time and this
is where the objects were recorded and
processed photographed
it's where the publications were written
it's where reisender and his family
stayed and they held court basically for
many many decades here is the road to
Harvard camp with a sign indicating what
you're about to see when you drive up to
visit the boss and in this aerial
photograph you can see by the 1930s it
was quite a cluster of buildings so
Reisner trained many of the Egyptians in
photographic methods and so for most of
the expedition it was Egyptians such as
Muhammad Ani Ibrahim who was taking the
bulk of the images on these glass plate
negatives in the photograph here you see
Mohammad Shah Diouf was actually shoeing
a little puppy named Patrick cups away
from the glass plates because they're
trying to make printing out paper prints
based on sunlight here so you don't want
your dog kicking up sand in the middle
of the photographs the Egyptians were
running the photo
graphic studio and here is hugg ahmed
joseph who is an employee of the
egyptian museum and a master conservator
Reisner enlisted his help to help
restore the funeral furniture of Queen
had a Paris and the photograph here you
see Osman Yosef making a copy of the
curtain box of the Queen after he's
already restored the original in new
wood his handiwork can be seen in the
Egyptian Museum Cairo today and later
Yousef became quite famous as the man
who restored the Khufu boat discovered
in 1954 here again is the aerial view of
Harvard camp and then in recent years
what it looked like semi restored
sometimes put to use and sometimes not
and now unfortunately demolished once
and for all because part of the tourist
pathway for an electric train was
intended to go right through this area
so Harvard camp itself is no more but
this is the view standing in that area
looking eastwards towards the Khafre and
Khufu pyramids and the Nile Valley in
the distance it was a spectacular place
to live when Reisner turned 70 he had a
special surprise birthday party and all
the men gathered and the workmen and the
families and here they are sitting in
the courtyard of Harvard camp handing
out presents and taking photographs this
was his family the men came and
congratulated him one by one on reaching
the ripe old age of 70 years old and of
course he wasn't going to slow down he
kept on going some of the events are
actually quite interesting and amusing
this photograph confused me for a long
time from 1938 there in the courtyard of
Harvard camp the men have pickaxes
everyone's laughing and there's an
individual named mr. Schechter talking
to Reisner eventually I realized what
this was it was the dress rehearsal for
a live radio broadcast to happen that
night of course late at night in Cairo
makes it back live at dinner time in the
US and many many newspaper articles
recorded this event so Reisner was
interviewed his daughter was interviewed
several other Egyptologists spoke and in
the background the Egyptians were making
the digging songs and digging noises
with their pickaxes and that's what that
photograph was it was a rehearsal for
the first ever live radio broadcast
via NBC from Cairo around the world
along the way a few individuals were
particularly valuable to rised her side
Ahmed Zayed began as a boy carrying the
photographic equipment and stayed with
Reisner for decades unfortunately he
died suddenly in 1926 during the
excavation of the shaft tomb of Hedda
Paris but he left behind some talented
family members and two of his sons
stepped in Mohammed Saeed and Mahmoud
Sian
Mohammed ran the dig for the rest of
reissner's career Mahmoud learned
English and was up at the dig camp
taking dictation and helping prepare a
lot of the manuscripts these two
first-rate individuals had inherited all
the intelligence and the skills of their
father and they were like sons to
Reisner without him he would not have
been able to run the excavation I was
fortunate enough to meet one of the sons
of Mohammed side in recent years and
here he is and he had some of the Arabic
Diaries that his father and uncle had
been recording and thanks to him they
are now part of our excavation
documentation it was a great privilege
to go back in time and hear the stories
of someone who knew Reisner and as a boy
had played up at Harvard camp and
watched all the great discoveries of the
expedition unfold
you